♪ ♪ ♪
- Michel vient retourner
ses bouteilles de vin dans
cette SAQ, pas parce que
son vin est bouchonné.
- Je trouve ça extraordinaire,
vraiment la technologie.
- Mais plutôt pour aller
consigner ses contenants.
Dans le cadre de la
modernisation de la Loi sur la
consigne, sept projets pilotes
sont en place dans 6 villes du
Québec jusqu'au 31 janvier 2022.
Ici, Michel peut rapporter
les contenants de boisson
en plastique, en verre
ou en métal grâce
à une gobeuse automatisée.
SONIA GAGNÉ, présidente-
directrice générale Recyc-Québec
- Les projets pilotes proposent
différents types de récupération
de contenants de manière
à pouvoir évaluer quelles
sont les meilleures manières
en fonction des régions
qui sont visées.
- La nouvelle loi prévoit que
les entreprises qui mettent
en marché les contenants sont
responsables de la gestion
des matières résiduelles.
À elle seule, la SAQ met
en marché plus de 200 millions
de bouteilles de verre par
année. La société d'État, qui a
longtemps misé sur la collecte
sélective, se dit prête
pour le grand virage.
MARIE-HÉLÈNE LAGACÉ, Affaires
publiques et communications SAQ
- Ça fait plus de 30 ans
qu'on prend action là-dessus,
qu'on investit dans la collecte
sélective, dans la valorisation
du verre. Mais à un moment
donné, il a fallu se rendre
compte que, malgré des taux
de récupération très élevés,
plus de 90 %, il y a seulement
environ 30 du verre qui était
réellement recyclé à la fin.
- La nouvelle consigne permettra
de produire un verre beaucoup
plus pur que celui retrouvé
pêle-mêle dans le bac
de recyclage, une pureté
nécessaire pour le recyclage
du verre.
- Enfin, c'est le gros bon sens!
- Robert Julien, de chez
2M Ressources, un conditionneur
de verre, attendait ce moment.
ROBERT JULIEN, premier vice-
président, 2M Ressources Inc
- Avant, c'était une économie
linéaire, donc post-
consommation. C'était
directement l'enfouissement,
tous ces emballages-là.
Là, aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on
veut en faire vraiment...
donner son sens au circulaire.
Et la beauté de la chose
du verre, c'est qu'un coup
qu'il est conditionné,
refait en bouteille,
il se le fait à l'infini.
- C'est donc un changement
majeur pour l'environnement,
selon Karel Ménard.
KAREL MÉNARD, Front commun qué.,
gestion écologique des déchets
- Oui, c'est une révolution
parce que c'est bien beau
récupérer des dizaines
ou des centaines de millions
de bouteilles, bien, il faut
avoir un système de collecte
efficace, faut avoir aussi
un système de conditionnement.
On peut pas seulement envoyer
une bouteille comme ça chez
un recycleur; il faut la
préparer, la conditionner.
Et il faut avoir les recycleurs
et le marché pour.
- Et le marché est prêt,
croit Robert Julien.
- Le gisement de la nouvelle
consigne au Québec va faire
en sorte qu'on va être capable
fournir, de répondre à une
demande, parce que, vraiment,
en ce moment, on ne répond
pas à la demande.
- Les citoyens devront
développer de nouvelles
habitudes et se déplacer.
Recyc-Québec croit qu'il faut
simplement user de stratégie.
- Les projets pilotes visent
justement à tester le geste
des citoyens par rapport à
son... à sa routine quotidienne.
Donc, les points de dépôt sont
placés de telle façon qu'ils
sont entre plusieurs commerces,
par exemple.
- Michel, lui, n'y voit aucun
problème.
- Une inquiétude du
consommateur, c'est sûr.
Un peu comme le compost.
- La consigne élargie devrait
officiellement être mise
en place dès décembre 2022.
Les montants de consigne seront
établis à 25 cents pour les
bouteilles de vin et spiritueux
et 10 cents pour tous les autres
conteneurs.
Ici, Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, M